Mức phạt tương tự cũng được áp dụng đủ về hàng B không leo gió mắm.
Cho chó, hoặc không sích giữ chó, không cũng người giát khi đưa chó rất nơi công cầu.
Ghi định được ban hàng nhằm tăng cường của lý vật nguy, phong ngường,
vui cơ lây lan dịch bệnh và bảo đam, ăn toàn cho công đông.
Nó ai các quy định lên qua đến vật nguy, ghi định cũng quy định nhiều mức sự phạt,
lời bởi các hàng Bp phạm trong lĩnh vực thuý, như chè dấu, không khai bảo dịch bệnh,
vất sắc nộn vật mắc bệnh giả mù trường.
Sử dụng thuốc thuốc thuốc thuốc y không gió nguồn đó, hát hả xử dụng.
Chào chính phủ, mức phạt tối đã đồ về B phạm hàng chính trong lĩnh vực thuốc y,
lan nắm mươi chỗ đồng đồ về cả nhân và mù chăm chỗ đồng đồ về tổ chất.